[Música]
sabías que una ostra
tan sólo una filtra entre 120 y 160
litros de agua al día
puede alimentarse por sí sola y lo más
interesante ser un filtro eliminando
bacterias de e.coli en menos de 8 horas
según la investigación del científico
ruin martins
me pongo a pensar un poco que el día del
trabajo de esta pequeña ostra y me la
imagino en un ambiente sucio en un
ambiente desagradable en el cual ella no
puede ver más allá que lo que tiene
enfrente
pero pasadas las 8 horas ella solamente
ve claridad
sin embargo nuestra mente podría
funcionar de la misma manera
porque lograríamos purificar y filtrar
todas estas malas experiencias malas
actitudes todas esas cosas que no nos
permiten tener una visibilidad clara de
nuestras metas
pues el día de hoy tú serás esa ostra
y te preguntarás qué por qué y es que
muchas veces como humanos nos
encontramos en situaciones que nos ponen
en la misma posición que la otra y no
solamente en lugares sucios y
desagradables también nos podemos
encontrar con malas amistades falta de
oportunidades etcétera etcétera
nuestra meta estando en modo ostra
debiera de ser que cuando las personas
consideren que eso que está ahí no te
funciona que eso no te puede ser útil
para alcanzar tus sueños tú lo
conviertas en algo productivo
y si muchas personas no van a querer
cambiar su mentalidad inclusive no van a
querer ayudarte a cambiar eso que te
está dañando a ti ya tu comunidad
pero recordemos
hay dos tipos de personas
los que quieren mejorar y los que siguen
igual o incluso peor
el pensador esto pensaba no cita una
frase grandiosa y concreta
dice que muy pocas veces pensamos en lo
que realmente tenemos
pero pensamos muchas veces más en lo que
nos hace falta
la creación de mi emprendimiento se dio
de la misma manera en un lugar donde por
situaciones de violencia no pude dar a
conocer mis productos de la manera en
que me hubiese gustado
había muchas dificultades que me
hicieron pensar que no debía empezar a
hacer mi emprendimiento había 50 excusas
para dejarlo pero corrí por una para
empezarlo
en la actualidad mi emprendimiento está
por vía internet teniendo éxito
y si es que muchas veces no haga llegar
las herramientas como lo esperas muchas
veces te va a tocar crear tus propias
herramientas
y quizás es el lado que no nos gusta
como seres humanos no nos gusta mucho
trabajar por lo que queremos
pero si quieres tu éxito tendrás que
hacerlo
tenemos un gran ejemplo con las ostras
y es que cuando en ella se introduce
algo ajeno su cuerpo
ella como método de defensa reacciona
cubriendo eso con una capa de minerales
carbonato de calcio y una proteína
llamada colina
y dirán qué nombres tan raros pero lo
cubre y lo cubre y lo cubre y se crea lo
que nosotros el día de hoy conocemos
como una perla
algo tan grandioso como eso surgió de
siquiera un granito de arena un pedacito
de plástico algo que tú no verías útil
se convirtió en algo tan elegante algo
tan brilloso
pero no fue fácil
la creación de una sola perla dura entre
siete a diez años
una sola perla creo que quiero que mires
tumba no creo que todos bien en su mano
en este momento y piensen de qué tamaño
es la perla a comparación de su mano
algo así fue difícil de crearse pero
sigue siendo brilloso sigue siendo
elegante sigue siendo algo de lo que te
puede sentir orgulloso
tú eres ese filtro eres este generador
de cosas grandiosas de lo que nadie
espera
el día de hoy pregúntate qué vas a sacar
de esto
tenga en mente que lo que para otros es
malo tú lo puedes volver algo genial
se tuve ese filtro sé tú la persona que
convierte a cosas grandes y mucho más
grandes
y te aseguro que las puertas se abrirán
siempre que tú estés en modo ostra
[Aplausos]